[Music]
hello there
july is known as the slowest month of
the year when it comes to video game
releases
and i can confirm that theory is correct
but there is still quality to be found
this month for all budgets
and like usual i found a couple of free
games to tide you over if you're saving
your cash for another month
so let's crack on i'm including a dlc
first for watch dogs legion
this is bloodline and brings back aiden
pierce and wrench from watch dogs one
and two
both are coming over to sweary london to
steal a device which controls a robot
army
this had better be good after starting
his opponent the two martial art trained
hackers
joined forces to bring down a bigger
evil and that bad guy so happens to have
kidnapped aidan's nephew from watch dogs
one
he's back he's all grown up and uncle
aiden needs to rescue him again
watchdog's legion can be found regularly
at about half its original retail price
so if you've been sleeping on this one
now's a good time to jump back
in and you should know the cooperative
mode is fully operational with new end
game content
and get this in your eye holes there's
an upcoming zombie mode
too a zombie apocalypse in london with
spy gadgets like a james bond movie
this could be something special or it
could just be ridiculous fun with
friends
i just need to find some friends now it
looks like watchdog's legion has more to
offer than it did back on day one the
bloodline dlc drops on july 6th on
playstation 4
5 xbox series and pc
here's a quirky little game to take a
look at little devil inside
most people first saw this at the
playstation 5 showcase
and the greatest poo joke ever seen plop
now here's the thing
i can't find a release date for this
game except the month of july
and when reaching out to devs i got some
strange responses
like i do when a game comes to ps plus i
have nothing to back up that this is a
ps plus game but last month this
happened with operation tango it's
happened with oddworld in the past and
fall guys too
regardless of all that though little
devil inside is releasing in july
and from all the footage i've found i'm
still unsure what kind of game this is
it certainly looks like an rpg there's
side scrolling there's boss laying
there's aimless wandering there's
shooting
there's donkey riding we wait to see
what this game becomes
little devil inside drops on ps4 ps5 on
pc in july with switch
and xbox versions coming a little bit
later in the year
[Music]
hey we've already started talking about
free games so let's jump into that now
my plan this month was to show you this
trackmania 2020
and its new battle royale style
free-to-play mode
it's like four guys meets f1 but alas
there is an issue although i was
expecting the console version to be
ready by now
it sadly isn't so if you want to play
this it's just on pc at the moment
but at any moment it could drop on
console their website has been updated
with a platform button
but there's no other options but pc just
yet but it's okay
i found another vehicular battle game
instead in 2018 a pc game released
called heavy metal machines
and back in february this year it
released secretly on playstation
and now in july the full release is upon
us so have a look-see
the aim of this car mode is to transport
a bomb to the enemy base using a vehicle
sounds simple right you even have an
online team of friends to help you out
there's also a full team of enemies set
to do the same thing to your base
and that's the loop if you've ever
played micro machines it's like that
mixed with the rocket league
in a moba if you're old enough to have
played rock and roll racing it's
it's very similar to that the game
monetizes via a battle pass and some
booster mechanics for xp
so there is a little pay to win mechanic
aspect but nothing that breaks the game
think you'll try it if you do it's out
right now on playstation xbox
and pc another free game you should know
of
is one you'll need to play for a long
time to receive everything for free but
it is possible
let me explain capcom arcade stadium is
a hub
where a host of their arcade games from
the 80s and 90s
are kept at face value everything does
cost money
not much but it is there well it's
possible to slowly build up this entire
arcade back catalog
for free right now the hub can be
downloaded which includes the warplane
game
1943 and capcom have confirmed further
promotions are planned
especially on ps plus for example last
month
ghosts and goblins was free to download
but that vanished before i was able to
share the news
i'll continue to monitor it and shout
out each month when something is added
for free
so if your dad tells you about how great
the arcades were in the 1990s
you can show him your digital arcade
capcom
arcade stadium is out right now on
playstation pc switch and xbox
whilst we're talking about free games a
quick note about one i told you about
last month knockout city
if you miss the 10 free days you should
know that they've changed their free to
play access
to allow anyone to play completely free
until they reach level 25
it's quite a lot of time i've got to say
definitely enough time to play without
having to shell over any cash
okay so that's four free games let's
call that two
and move back to full price games
[Music]
well actually a low budget game we have
a stadia exclusive which is now
releasing on ps4 pc and xbox
ox must die 3. i always saw this as a
game which inspired fortnite save the
world
setting up traps for oncoming waves of
orcs and surviving at
all costs box must die 3 is the natural
evolution to the series with new weapons
powers and of course traps if tower
defense games are your bag
ox must die 3 is worth your time july
23rd
if you're interested
next up samurai warriors 5. musu games
are still alive and thrashing
the core to this style of game is going
up against insurmountable odds
with your trusty katana and defeating
thousands upon thousands of enemies
i mean you'll regularly get 10 000 hit
combos without batting an eyelid the
progression system has been evolved
which gives upgrades to equipment
and access to new moves almost after
every single mission
this builds up your arsenal and in a few
hours you'll be wielding a ridiculous
array of moves
effortlessly the previews of samurai
warriors 5 have confirmed the
improvements to storytelling and the
hard mode has been tweaked
and it will really give you a fight like
never before if you want to let out your
inner samurai
check it out on ps4 switch xbox and pc
on july 27th
and that reminds me the dynasty warriors
movie releases in july
i just thought you should know it's
ridiculous
[Music]
finally chris tales i was completely
oblivious to this game but quickly found
out there is a huge following of this
loved rpg
essentially chris tales is a turn-based
jrpg it's quite run-of-the-mill
but there's something very impressive
added on top it has a time
travel function for example when
fighting an impossible boss with a shiny
metal shield
you can use water in your current time
then send that boss into the future
so that shield corrodes and rusts over
time therefore making this
unstoppable boss very beatable i found
that really interesting chris tales
drops on switch ps4 ps5
xbox pc and stadia so basically
absolutely everywhere
july 20th if you find this interesting
so eight games to grab your attention
over july 2021
this will hopefully be the last quiet
month of the year and the big releases
will start hitting us in the face
very very soon i'm adam you're awesome
thanks for staying this far
if if you are still here at this point
right
i like turtles in the comments and i
will do my best to find you and reply
thank you very much much appreciated
i'll see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]